today is Richards birthday happy
birthday Richard I don't know if you're
there whose birthday how well do you
think he is cuz he looks like he's a
hundred what how well do you think yeah
I got a figure he's about fifty now
forty six but he looks really yeah yeah
I was being nice
richard has spent a thousand dollars on
alcohol since we last left world you got
where are you Richard you there hey
Richard hey you've grown a big beard huh
yeah no shaving big kids Tim oh my god
where is he
[Music]
the guy said it's like a torture chamber
it's all like Halloween memorabilia and
monster masks and it was almost like he
had done it on purpose but that really
is his basement what do you mean you
spend a thousand bucks on alcohol what
did you buy a bunch of it just somewhere
we got it just in case the store shut
down I always knew your dad liked if the
[ __ ] hit the fan that his dad would know
how to survive yeah he's the guy who's
gonna make it he's the last man standing
you know what I mean his father is just
a [ __ ] outdoorsman extraordinary you
know they don't have to go the grocery
store I mean I thought about it if it
gets much worse I might head out west it
may take the family to his farm raw wild
Richard has been locked up in his house
he has watched the recent Super Bowl
specifically the last eight minutes when
Kansas City won oh really he's watched
it hundreds and hundreds of times over
and over again is that correct yeah
cheers me up kind of keeps my mind off
all this stuff I mean I can never thank
you enough for that Howard that was like
the last big thing that kind of happened
before all all hell broke loose do you
get as excited do you jump up and down
and scream the same way yeah unless
Bobby's taking a nap and I don't want to
wake you mom
you